[Music]
[Applause]
spring and greg olsen fox nfl analyst
former nfl tight end and uh
greg has talked about this before george
kittle running tight end university
presented by charmin for the second year
tight ends from around the nfl meet in
nashville
june 22nd through the 24th and they
participate in a variety of activities
film study on field drills over 50 pro
tight ends attended last year this year
75 are expected to be involved and greg
joins us now are quarterbacks allowed to
go to tight end university
yeah i think we're gonna get i think
we're gonna get a few guys to come we're
trying to get um trying to get mahomes
kelsey kelsey's telling us that he
thinks he can get home the homes that
would be awesome um last year we had
beathard from used to play with kittle
out in san francisco
um
trying to get wilson from new york uh to
come to join us so we got we're trying
to get josh allen so we we got a handful
of guys that we're confident we're gonna
end up getting down there and we need
some guys to spin it for us on the field
and uh
and make the most of our time but it's
been an awesome event as you said we're
gonna have over 75 if not more guys um
you know anybody from an undrafted
rookie all the way to 15-year veteran so
it's it's a really special event and
guys really loved it last year and so
much so that we're going to come back
and do it again
what's late night like at titan
university that's a that's a good
question i would say that's probably the
highlight of some of the guys uh weeks
and we we do get a lot of work we get a
lot of work done we spent you know hours
in the in the classrooms we spent hours
on the fields working but um wednesday
and thursday night wednesday night last
year after our kind of welcome party we
had like a little rooftop at the hotel
downtown we welcomed everybody and then
afterwards everybody went downtown to
the kind of honky tonks and the bars
down in in downtown and um we had a
great time i mean you see 25 30 6'5 guys
walking into the bar and everyone's like
looking at us like we're from a
different planet um but it was uh we had
a great time and then bud light this
year is gonna host like a thursday night
uh party downtown for all the guys after
a day of training and a day on the field
we're gonna get everybody together so
it's been um it's a nice mix of social
camaraderie hanging out enjoying
nashville but also realizing that we're
there to kind of spend time with each
other in the classroom on the field and
uh and getting better is gronk going to
go this year is he considered a tight
end in the nfl
he is considered a tight end in the nfl
yes um we i don't know we've invited
gronk the last two years he wasn't able
to make it last year hopefully he can
make it this year but uh the the invite
is obviously out for him to to be
involved and we would love to see him
whether he plays this year i don't know
where all that stands but uh he's
definitely invited we'd love to have him
we'd love to get you know where i think
whitton's going to come we're trying to
get um tony gonzalez and some of the
former players to come um
i just think it's fun to represent the
entire spectrum you know undrafted guys
that are just fresh off their first
rookie otas and minicamp and then guys
who are retired and have done this at a
high level for a long time and now are
kind of looking back on it as former
players and can share that perspective
and point of view with a lot of the
young guys in the room why haven't
salaries caught up
with that position it still feels like
tight ends and running backs are
underpaid
yeah you know i think there's a lot of
reasons for it i think when you when you
root it back into the old collective
bargaining agreement so think anything
pre-2011
the guys at the positions that every
year the old the old cba the old draft
was if you were a top 10 pick you give
or take became the highest paid guy at
your position and it was mostly
quarterbacks wide receivers pass rushers
you know and a lot of the more highly
paid guys so now when you're a veteran
and all of a sudden you know matt
stafford is the number one overall pick
well all of a sudden that next year
every veteran quarterback has a new
marker to climb well for so long right
we had the same guys the tony gonzalez's
of the world the witness of the world
for so long they were always the
benchmark and they would just negotiate
against themselves it wasn't really
until gronk kind of got us into that
next level and then kelsey and kittle
now have really jumped it they took it
up into the 15-16 and you see everybody
else kind of trailing you need young
guys to continue to one up the top guy
when ten years ago and the one guy
dominates the position it's very hard to
justify someone else making more than
travis kelsey so as long as travis
kelsey's the top barometer
he's gonna pretty much put the ceiling
on the position that's the challenge
that's faced um
you know at the position for so long and
you know we just we're still playing
catch-up any question who's the greatest
tight end of all time
i yeah i i do i think you you can kind
of throw a handful of names into the box
like i've always for years thought it
was tony gonzalez i just think when you
look at his longevity his durability and
then just his production you know only
to be outdone by jerry rice right i mean
you start thinking about that when you
look at the sheer volume of catches and
yards and production that tony had over
maybe 17 years or whatever it was
it's unprecedented it's just incredible
to think if you extrapolate if i had a
thousand yards every year
how many years would i need to do it to
even come close to tony so i think
tony was always that i thought but now
in this modern age you look you think of
gronk you think that travis kelsey is
really on his way but you know six years
in a row over a thousand yards this
modern era of tight ends has introduced
a lot of new names to what was always
kind of dominated by maybe shannon sharp
and tony g
there's now the witness of the world
there's now you know gronks of the world
travis is on his way kittle maybe one
day as you know obviously he's still a
little younger it's
the position has a lot more guys now
that can throw their names into that hat
we're talking to greg olson the fox nfl
analyst and uh it's tight end university
presented by charming second uh year
they've had this they're expecting 75
tight ends to be involved there
congratulations on uh being the analyst
for the super bowl how were you told
well that was a long process uh there
was a lot that went in ever since joe
and troy left um you know there was a
lot of speculation and rumor and we were
you know we were having dialogue with
them at times throughout the entire
process but of course they were
working through their own stuff
internally and then of course it came
out that that um that tom was gonna take
the job whenever he ended up retiring so
we weren't really sure what that meant
for me and where we thing but you know
they immediately reached out and and
we've been having good dialogue you know
the deal is not done nothing's signed
sealed and delivered but we're
optimistic that we're going to be able
to um you know at least for this year
you know call the a team call super bowl
call playoff games work with kevin
burkhart who was my partner last year
he's been a friend of mine for a long
time
um you know even if i get one year at it
i'm gonna try to kill it i'm gonna try
to
make the fun season people tune in
really enjoy our broadcast and uh
hopefully tom plays for a few more years
what advice would you give tom brady
being an analyst
i don't know i don't know how much i
could tell tom i think obviously
he i'm sure he's going to do just fine
but you know the thing the big i'll say
this the biggest thing that i learned
is you know for so long we all see the
game a certain way when we sit in
meetings and you're accustomed to
talking to coaches and players that
speak your language understand what you
mean
there's a very fine balance calling the
games between
you don't want to dumb it down and take
away from the complex nature that makes
football so special and so interesting
and why people tune in in the millions
to watch it but you also can't talk on
air like i would talk to my coach or
like i would talk to a current player or
teammate who understands the language
the language and terminology because you
can lose a lot of people right so
there's two ends to that spectrum
threading that needle
is a very delicate balance and that was
something i really enjoyed i loved
pointing out the
intricacies of the game and here's what
we would call it and this is what the
receiver is thinking in his mind and
whatnot but then also not going
overboard that everybody's sitting at
home drinking a beer on a sunday is lost
they have no idea what i'm talking about
so i enjoyed that balance of it so that
that was probably the biggest lesson i
learned i'm sure tom will be just fine
and probably doesn't need my advice but
um
that was something that i enjoyed but
also something that i had to learn and
sometimes you learn
just by doing it and i talked to
analysts when i worked for mbc with
football night in america and i would
always say
you got to speak in sound bites
you can't go long you got to say it see
it and say it and then get out of the
way see it say it and get out of the way
that'll be the hard part i think for
brady is he'll see it but can you say it
and do it in a way that you're going to
be able to get your point across
and then wait for the next play how did
you learn how to do that or
try to master that
no it's a great point i mean i
fortunately had a chance to call a few
games um at the end of my career um one
of them was with kevin um you know in
the three-man booth with him and charles
davis back in 17 and that was one of the
first pieces of advice um years back
before i did my audition i had an
opportunity to speak with troy aikman
and just kind of pick his brain and he
gave me that exact advice you just said
he's like listen get in get out make
your point don't try to make five make a
point that you think's the most
important aspect and if there's a couple
other things you'll have time as the
game unfolds to come back to it don't
try to jam it all into one thing so just
like you were saying i don't think
people realize how much is you know how
many boundaries there are to when you
can and can't speak right you have your
your play-by-play guy who owns part of
the broadcast and he's got to own that
and get out of his way you got producers
that are getting in advertisement reads
and they're getting in commercial breaks
and they're getting in pre-recorded
segments and stat lines and graphics so
it's not you know everyone we all watch
the manning show and what's so cool
about it is
they're just talking and it's natural
and it's like a bunch of guys sitting
around drinking having a beer watching a
game and it feels so natural when you
call an actual game we all wish we could
just talk forever we wish we could talk
over the play or over the referee
calling but you can't you're kind of
bounded by what's going on in the game
so that takes a little there's a little
feel and a little kind of process to to
calling a game the easiest part is
seeing the game and talking football the
hardest part for guys former players is
can you get the mechanics and the you
know kind of the play by can you fit
into gold that the broadcast requires
let me ask you about your uh former
quarterback before i let you go if cam
newton doesn't play another down in the
nfl
is he a hall of famer
i think so i i think you know obviously
i'm biased you know cam and i
we we we were at it together for a long
time and accomplished a lot of cool
things together i i just think he really
transcended and changed the way people
viewed the quarterback position right
there was always the running
quarterbacks and there was always the
passing quarterbacks and we kind of
always put them in two separate boxes
and would only compare runners to
runners and passers to passers and then
all of a sudden this big old dude came
into the league and he was jumping over
guys he was the best third down back and
the best fourth down back in the best
goal line back but then he also could
drop back on third down and play from
the pocket and deliver the ball on time
and had a big arm and play traditional
quarterback like we all are accustomed
to seeing he brought in a lot of the
college auto stuff a lot of the designed
quarterback reads
there wasn't a lot of guys doing that
and the passing and the traditional
passing game that we were doing early on
you know in 2011 12 13 with cam so i
just think he brought that element to
the nfl um
and i think anybody who
moves the game forward anybody who who
transcends kind of the way things used
to be and brings it into a new era
deserve to be recognized for that
before i let you go i love to be the
conduit to my audience to give them
something that maybe they didn't realize
i'll ask you give us the tight end who
might not be on our radar right now
we're going to be talking about this
upcoming season
i you know i i think i think it's a
great question if you would have asked
me this last year the guy i came away i
told this story a few times last year
coming off those fields down in
nashville i knew who darren waller was
right i had followed him i knew who he
was but at the time he wasn't gronk he
wasn't kiddle and kelsey and the names
that we all kind of know offhand but i
walked off that field and he was on with
50 other nfl tight ends everybody's 6'4
everybody's 250 they could all run
and he was just different he just looked
different he ran different his body was
different every i walked off and i was
like this dude is unbelievable so i mean
he's he's now a household name he's a
guy that we all saw and obviously had
another great year this past year you
know probably he'll be you know maybe
the next highest paid tight end at the
position you know we talk about guys can
he become higher you know higher paid
than than kelseen kittle will see but
he was a guy i just was blown away by
him and just his approach his mentality
his physical qualities who's that next
guy i'm not sure i'm anxious to go see
some of these guys in person you know i
see him on game film i see him on tape
but until you kind of see him up close
and personal
it always makes a big difference so i'm
looking forward to that good to talk to
you again greg good luck with everything
uh tight end university and of course
working for fox this upcoming season
i appreciate it thanks for having me on
the uh tight end university presented by
charmin second year that they will do
this and they're expecting 75 of those
tight ends
in nashville